covering some of the civilian casualties
a couple in your report the numbers are
in the hundreds according to the u.n and
that is almost surely an undercount that
reported ceasefire that chris mentioned
the agreement this morning follows a
series of russian attacks new attacks
that once again left civilians around
the country shell-shocked charlie
dagetta filed this report from a battle
zone near kiev
we headed to the northern outskirts of
the capitol to a suburb that has come
under heavy bombardment a new front line
in the russian offensive
you can see the incredible damage
that's been done here from russian
artillery now this is just a residential
home in a residential neighborhood no
military target and these are the areas
that are coming under attack just
outside the capitol itself now which has
caused so many people to flee in anger
and in fear even as they're coming under
attack
we're hoping to visit the hospital where
dozens of people have been treated they
are literally shelling residential
neighborhoods
with weapons that aren't directed and
wherever they land they land families
who could escape have already fled those
who could not sought shelter at a
children's holiday camp
which is where we found tatiana the
deputy manager in a state of shock
are you going to be okay
yeah
are you sure yeah
you look very friendly first time that i
have christ first time for the 11 days
sorry
i'm obsessed i'm a woman
please help us i ask you
next could be here i ask you god
we did go down where we found the
elderly and young children hiding out
even as thunderous explosions rang out
they tell us has been so ferocious the
ground shakes they check each other to
see if they're still alive after each
explosion we had to wait for a break in
the shelling ourselves to make our way
to that hospital soldiers and civilians
blindsided unable to process the
relentless bombardment powerless to do
anything about it
for cbs mornings charlie dagetta in
harenka on the outskirts of the capitol